so before we get started I just want to
give a huge thank you to arc light for
being such an awesome partner and also
to Universal for letting us screen the
movie before it's in theaters gentlemen
congratulations thank you so Leah I want
to start with you what did you do on
this movie because it's all one take
absolutely nothing it was it was a dream
job
seriously though there was a lot of
obviously pre-planning in the execution
of these extended takes to get them to
be seamless and hopefully they were
seamless apart from the one scripted cut
where Scofield gets shot in the head and
we cut to black
oh there's Sam perfect timing Sam we've
run out of things so sorry sorry I'm
late thank you for joining us caught in
traffic sorry about just gonna tell the
story of your grandfather then but you
came here so were you really you could
probably do it word for word I'm sure
Roger goodbye now sorry I interrupted I
was asking what exactly he did on the
movie because it was offering absolutely
nothing he just needed he just needed a
paycheck first yeah so also would you
would you
he can't say what what he did but I can
say he was actually an incredibly
crucial part of the whole process
because there's a there's a great David
Mamet line about the editor he says in
the cutting room
the director is serving two masters the
movie and himself is the editors job to
just serve the movie
Lia's an unerring way of of judging
performance and in terms of feedback and
actually trying to give us a sense of
the movie that we were making he was he
was crucial and stitching together the
shots obviously but not just that but
creating a sound world and tent music
and and and so we had a sense of a jet a
full movie fully realized movie coming
straight back to us kind of the day
after we shot it and often as a director
you you tend to if you don't let say
twenty eight takes or twenty nine takes
you tend to get drawn to take 27 28 29
and Lee has a way of he doesn't like
knowing what my selected take is he
watches them all every single thing we
shoot and he would often say I know
there was a mistake in take 12 but we
can deal with that look at take 12 again
and he was always right and there were
two or three occasions when I sense
something was wrong with the scene and
he gave feedback and we reshot it and it
was really because of Lee's feedback so
it was like having another filmmaker
working with me because that's what he
is and so he was actually joking aside a
pivotal part of it he can't say that
about himself because that would sound
grand but but I can I would have
but it sounded better coming from you I
think I speak for everyone who watches
this film that we really want to see how
this thing was made please tell me
there's like a two three-hour
documentary on the making of this movie
sadly not there there was a an e PK crew
with us the whole time but you know the
most interesting part of it in many ways
was the six months of prep because we
even know we only shot for 65 days was
it only but I mean for a movie this
scale that's not actually that long and
certainly less than a half of a Bond
movie for example it was it was made
many times before that because we had to
start on empty fields with the boys with
scripts in their hands and we literally
me and Roger and the boys and a couple
of other folk just walking through those
empty spaces marking out the journey
with flags and poles and only then could
we start to construct the trenches no
man's land
quarry's orchards farm houses the entire
set the entire thing was built around
the actors built around the script built
around the journey that they took and we
we had to account for every step every
pause every and and within that
obviously it was also built for the
journey of the camera so Minh many ways
would have been to cover everything that
happened almost before we started
shooting I'm curious when did you when
did you realize that you wanted how long
had you been thinking about doing
something along these lines in terms of
trying to make it feel like one take not
that long to be honest with you III
didn't think oh I've got to finds a
subject matter that I can do in one take
I did enjoy we did the first eight
minutes of Spectre as one shot and that
was hugely enjoyable and challenging
because it was four thousand costumed
extras and a whole of Mexico City shut
down and
you know all that that sort of stuff so
I felt like a real proper movie director
on those few days but I wasn't looking
for some way of using that I it was when
I had the idea for the movie and I felt
it should be told in two hours of real
time it then felt like a logical
progression from that moment that we
would experience every passing second
with the men and understand distance and
physical difficulty and geography with
them you know of all it's a very present
tense story but it's a very present
tense war as well you know you it was
not a war of it there was no
communication so you know men only saw
just as far as they could see as it were
you know and it felt like the right way
to tell the story and because it came
with the material it felt like a single
piece content and form combined and I
think that's why everyone you know once
they read the script rogering including
particularly Roger of course was my
chief collaborator from from the word go
understood it was it was integral to the
story rather than it just being
something that was tacked on Roger
talked a little bit about what was that
first phone call like or first meeting
when he hit you up with this is what I'm
thinking about doing and did you even
was it even a like a moment where you're
like this is we're not doing this no he
just sent me the script he didn't talk
about the one shot he just said it was I
forget what he said it was just a film
set in World War one so I was
immediately hooked but the front page of
the script said it was you know this is
envisioned as a single shot in real time
so I thought that was kind of odd
I saw some of the behind-the-scenes
footage and saw some of the camera rigs
that were designed for this could you
sort of talk about what you had to do to
actually bring this to life and you know
the technology you sort of had to
develop yeah well I don't think it's a
film could have been made a few years
ago I mean it's a combination of you
know small digital camera you know some
rigs that have been around for a while
like there's some Steadicam work in it
but mostly it's shot on a little remote
head called a stable eye that's only
been out for a couple of years it's made
in England by a guy called Dave Rieff
you know and then we peek a bakkoutou is
a Steadicam operator he invented a
little it's like a little Steadicam
posts that we put the stable iron
because you know you might not think it
but going down those trenches in front
of somebody it's like really hard
especially when there's a foot of mud
and it's slipping around as all the
extras and stuff so Peter invented this
little pod so he could run forward but
the cameras over his shoulder and I'm
operating it remotely on little
stabilized head and then he gets at the
end of it you know corner of a trench
I need swing himself around and then
start running after them it's pretty
neat I mean you wouldn't think that was
the hardest shot but it probably was
it's crazy what you guys accomplished on
this I am curious and I think a lot of
people are curious when you watch this
which was the shot for you or which was
the day that you're like you know
throwing [ __ ] in the air and like come
on this is the you know what I mean the
backbreaking day the difficult shots in
the movie for me were the shots actually
that were about performance you know
because the that the engineering as
Roger says we did beforehand a little
bit I mean there's a lot of discussion
about how but the why of it is in a may
more interesting you know
and Roger and I started with why for
about three months we just talked about
well where should the camera go and the
only rule we had was that's not worry
too much about the engineering yet let's
just imagine where we feel it should go
to express the emotion of the scene to
express what we need to express that's
important for the story and and so that
dance that was created between the
choreography really between the camera
and the characters in the landscape all
three of which are moving all the time
it almost never stops and even when we
do stop camera often continues because
it's expressing something about the
scene so for example in Blake's death
when he's wounded the camera circles him
a couple of times that's sort of it
that's instinct that's just me and Raj
again what about this what about that
and you know unless we both agreed on it
then we didn't do it really
and and I obviously trust him implicitly
and and but it was it was about trying
to develop a language for the camera
that was specific to our movie and we
couldn't find any other movies in which
the camera was used in this way and with
their other one-shot movies but they're
all different in many ways I mean one I
admire Burres Birdman but Birdman's
interiors and it takes place over four
days it's a nice dream like you know and
it almost goes in circles through the
same locations it's quite different this
is very linear constantly moving forward
so you know we talk about other movies
but we couldn't find anything that was
so really we we ended up you know it's
good for us really because it we had to
work it out ourselves there was no other
there was nothing we could refer to but
the difficult days when you've rehearsed
the camera move you know and and thought
about the journey very carefully the
difficulty with a movie like this is
combining with the precision you the
precision you need with camera with
spontaneity in front of the camera you
don't want people over rehearsal robotic
in front of the camera so for me the
obviously did the most difficult day was
Blake's death because I had to try and
stop Dean giving a performance until we
were ready to capture that performance
and if you think about that shot it was
something like six and a half seven
minutes it's a long long time
and and even if the camera been in the
wrong place for one second if it's her
after he dies even when Scofield puts
the rings in his pocket or it comes
around behind Scofield and you see the
the photograph that he's taken out of
his pocket covered in blood any of those
little things go wrong and the whole
take is unusable the whole thing you
can't just say oh we'll use the first
bit because there's nowhere to car so we
had to it's that that balance between
trying to find the right moment where
the kid person gives the performance and
making sure cameras ready to capture it
and they haven't used up all their all
their good stuff while the cameras still
learning the shot so that's the most
difficult thing the the one that we
probably storyboarded and debated the
most Roger and I was going across the
canal I don't know why that was but I
suppose it was something to do with the
fact I didn't want Scofield to suddenly
turn to James Bond you know and and be
able to suddenly become a hero an action
hero you know if there was heroism the
movie it was always accidental heroism
the heroism of a good man trying to do
the best in the circumstances and
finding impossibly huge reserves of of
bravery almost when he himself didn't
know he was capable of doing that and so
trying to test every moment out so it
didn't seem too extraordinary what he
was doing but on a human level
completely extraordinary so it was just
that balance and and and and it had to
be in the shot
you know and the way that it was
constructed so that for me was probably
the one we maybe done four or five
different storyboards of that sequence
and we wrote it rewrote until we found
the right version that felt like it was
our movie so that's a very long answer I
apologize what was with how many did
what was the most takes you did on what
scene and what was the fewest you did
well the fewest we did in the movie in
other words the the the last shot of
Richard Madden the last the whole last
scene that starts really with with
Scofield coming out of the tent and goes
up to the end of the movie that's one
shot that was taewon so richard madness'
performing
take one him sitting in the tree take
one and the Sun coming out was take one
it was a you know moment Roger had
planned very carefully until that might
and but yeah that was over but we
probably did ten takes about I reckon we
never did less than ten and we did as
many as fifty I think maybe we did fifty
one Andrew Scott scene we may be gone up
into the 50s you know the result of
because of camera you weren't happy with
certain things performance for the upper
right it was just about dead yeah well
yeah that's the other thing you don't
you know some of these rigs that the
Trinity the big stable like the big
Steadicam rig it's just it's happy you
know and this is the athleticism
necessary to just do the do it in the
control necessary but know why it was
because want a you know five tapes were
gone because the lighter didn't work and
then then the cigarette went out and
then the props broke and then that you
know Blake couldn't get the this the gun
in its pocket remember all those ones on
it and yeah just that sort of stuff you
know which normally would not be an
issue but when you've got when you're
shooting for six minutes you know and
and it's an entire scene that like I
said you can have five minutes of magic
and then blade doesn't get the flare gun
in this pocket and the whole takes dead
and you have to start again and often
that takes another five or six days to
get back up to the place that you were
because the actors are thinking what did
I do in the good take that what I try to
remember what I did and you have to
again get them out of their own head and
start with an operating on instinct
again so it's a rhythm thing too you
know and at the same time I'm learning
about the rhythm of the scene and
thinking is there that pause is too long
should I be holding ammo is there a
possible look from Schofield to Blake
there you know should he take his his
cigarette from behind his ear before he
gets out of the dog or after he gets out
of it I mean these are you know should
Schofield be loading his gun on the line
or after the line and these are things
that you know now the irony is it sounds
like it that's a and it was it was a
tough day but it was just a day and and
the truth is in a conventional movie
if that scene had been broken up into
its component parts it probably would
have been 16 to 18 setups and it would
take in two days
so even though it was a tough day we got
through we read through it actually
quite fast by the standards of a normal
movie you know because we would have had
so many different setups to cover
because they're moving the whole time
and you'd have wanted to get every angle
but it makes you become very aware as a
director of how often you break things
up before you've actually understood the
scene because it's the easiest way to
shoot it you know you default very
quickly as a director - okay close up
close up over the shoulder over the
shoulder - shot moving shot fancy shot
every three scenes you know twelve set
up okay let's go you know and it's at
Hal a second you know editing is a
wonderful and powerful tool jump
space-time whatever but you have to edit
all the time do you always have to see
everyone when they're speaking their
line and the answer to that is no I mean
there's a lot of lines in this movie
that have spoken off-camera but that's
to do with the way the scenes staged and
and and and constructed for the show it
just means you have to think more about
it and plan it much more I'm curious
usually with every movie there's the
first cut the director's cut the final
cut I'm assuming with this the first cut
was the final cut it's my best first cop
ever man I was so on camera that yeah I
mean this film was basically being built
as Sam was shooting it and we were
constructing it sending it back and that
was informing what they were shooting
the next day rhythm pace you know we'd
be talking about that the whole time
because as Sam said and I had the same
experience as Roger did when he sent me
the script and he said it was to be seen
as one shot which I laughed at when I
read the script I continued to laugh
thinking they're gonna try but it did
and it worked really well
but yeah I've lost my train of thought
so just to confirm there's nothing on
the cutting room floor no deleted scenes
or is there just two seconds at the very
end when Scofield's leaning against the
tree where he's still closing inside no
there's nothing and be that she did ask
me though DVD there they did ask me any
deleted seemed like it's not even a
deleted second on deleted word you know
nothing is deleted no I mean it was very
you got to think about it because how do
you delete a thing cause then the
previous scene wouldn't match the next
scene because every shot we did we had
to we would have to watch the end of the
a and going into the B they had to match
I believe me I understand I just think
that it's good to actually establish
there is nothing do you know what I mean
um I am curious talk a little bit about
lighting this movie and the challenges
of doing these incredibly long takes and
trying to make the light perfect because
I believe and again I could be wrong you
were trying to film a lot in with clouds
in front of the Sun I mean just for the
look of the film we wanted it cloudy you
know it's meant to be late afternoon
going into evening you're never gonna
shoot in the sunlight it's gonna be all
over the place so that was a given but
also in terms of matching from from set
up to set up you know it made it much
more made much more sense to be in cloud
but that was a really hard thing even in
England I mean the first day of the
shoot there wasn't a cloud in the sky so
we didn't shoot and I'm I'm kind of
nervous wreck and it's but thankfully
the second day we had cloud and we
managed to get what we were supposed to
do the day before and that day so you
know there was a lot of watching the sky
and judging how long a cloud was going
to be in front of the Sun could we get a
six minute take with that one cloud or
is it going to break up but I'm you know
I'm a meteorologist now I really am
I want to do a fall I'm just you know
it's deceptive the movie though because
actually there are a lot of interiors
and they're a lot there are a lot of
there is a lot of brilliant interior
lighting and the nighttime town and and
you know Roger spent weeks you know
basically constructing torches for
example so that the boys could light
their own scene effectively when they go
into the into the German dug out the
tunnels you know the gas lamps that are
in their dugouts the the flares the the
the burning church at night which was an
immense rig and you know and don't you
know effectively dictated how that set
was constructed around it those are you
know extraordinary lighting rigs that
that Roger designed effectively and the
same with with the flares whom the
flares are on wires and a timed you know
so you've got a 32 second flame a 20
tuesdaya very an 18 second but we know I
could even remember the times as I'm
sure you can and exactly the direction
we built models with little miniature
lights you know so that we could see
where the shadows were going to stretch
to and you know and where to put the
buildings to create the shadows in the
first place and so that really was that
there is actually a large amount of
lighting but it's very very it's done a
water source and and it and it is artful
and we'll just bomb I actually wanted to
specifically ask you about filming the
with the flares because that it's so
beautiful to look at
can you talk about what went into for
you putting that stuff together well
that was our effects guide Dom tui I did
a fantastic job because he had these
players made up that were particular
color we wanted we didn't want you know
normally you can get blue flares that
are very bright but we didn't want blue
so he did a great job and Sam says we
Dennis Gassner in the art department
built a whole model of that town so we
had where the church like was going to
be and then these little wire rigs with
little LEDs on so we could see the
pattern of the light from the flares so
then we could mark out where the cranes
needed to be for Dom so Dom put them in
and computer-controlled the speed and
everything I mean it was incredibly
worked out
I was a bit skeptical actually the real
flares were going to work and I had a
kind of light made up to do it with her
life but I'm damn glad I didn't use it
it was good my nerdy question what kind
of cameras did you guys use and why it
was an Alexa
LF large-format mini and Arriflex it's
out now on the market but they made
three prototypes for us for this film so
it's the first film that shot with it
yeah well it's not much bigger than a
transistor radio I mean it's it's an
incredible image from a very tiny body
and then it was quite comic and it was
on a 200-foot crane because you know the
crane is enormous and it tiny tiny
little dot on the end of this crane you
know crane kind of seems to demand a big
old Panavision camera hey wearing away
and and and doesn't wear like that
anymore
did you guys use any sort of special
lenses or we use one lens a 40
millimeter well we actually are like
because in the German bunker we used 235
and on the river we used 247 but very
sparingly but basically again you gotta
shoot it on the same lens otherwise it's
not gonna match from shot to shot the
the perspective would be different so we
we chose a 40 because on a large-format
has a kind of field of view of something
slightly more than the 32 probably but
it's still got that fall-off and focus
of a 40 mil and for me it looked more
like the images you know the
black-and-white photographs from the
first world war we've got this so fairly
shallow depth of field that I mean I
really like that that format for this
eye what's interesting about this film
is that you really couldn't repeat any
locations did you repeat any locations
no right so talk a little bit about
having to essentially build all this
because it these trenches and everything
you guys did for the film it's it's
crazy yeah I mean in a normal movie you
would you would build you know 200 yards
of trenches and then you would you would
redress them you know put new background
in
around maybe doing Mexican reverse
shooting there whatever you you would
find a way to reuse them but there was
no way to do that obviously because it
was one continuous ever evolved and also
I was very concerned with that every
location the shift in atmosphere you
know the second line trench which is the
trench they come out on to after they
leave Aaron Moore's dugout Colin Firth
scene is quite different in atmosphere
you know passes through kotti bombed out
cottages and what I've been the
frontline trench has I sort of there's
something dead about it you know it's
waiting and more waiting and it it seems
like it's been hit more by shot shell
fire which it has so each each trench
needed a different personality even
different stretches of trench was one of
the things Roger and I realized when we
went to the northern France ourselves is
that you know the way the trench Falls
against the light in which direction
it's pointing in shifts that atmosphere
so even as you're walking it changes and
it's it's it feels some feel weird weird
little corners and others feel very
exposed and the parapets rising and
falling the whole time of me it has such
personality because they lived there I
mean they lived in this place for three
years you know four years so it needed
to feel layers and layers of margin
destruction and you know and and you
know people slept there shat there died
there I mean it's it's grim you know so
that feeling is particularly present on
the front line but what I said earlier
you you know we had to construct a set
for a journey and so it never stopped so
it's a ribbon it's an endless snake of a
set and the job seemed to me took you an
they got out of the trenches to feel
like the world went way beyond the frame
of the camera and because you know so
for example no-man's land which was a
big challenge for us because you know if
you it's a it's a good example in
microcosm if you look at a photo from
nomads side you just see flat land and
sticks of trees that's what you see
think oh it's just it's just flat mud
but then you enter that world it is an
entire world unto itself it's so land of
craters and dead horses and
flies and wires and and and you know
dead bodies and tanks and you know it
and every second of it has detail and
shifts in in in atmosphere and direction
and and the way the light falls all of
those things and also the way in which
the characters react to it you know
you've got one character who's already
established Schofield as somebody who
doesn't who knows what he's going to see
or has been there before and if you look
at it if you watch the movie again
you'll see that George and Schofield
doesn't look at anything on no Madison
he just keeps his eyes straight ahead he
doesn't look at the dead bodies or like
other flies Blake on the other hand is
watching everything and and it's so
you're telling two different sets of
stories there's two different ways of
coping with it as well and even within
that the relationship between the camera
sometimes it's the camera moving around
them sometimes it's them moving in
relation to the camera for example when
you go down into the big crater they
have to go around the perimeter of the
crater the camera skims across the
surface of the water so in that moment
you see in them small they disappear a
little bit into the mist then they
return again that sort of dance and you
know you've got a we weren't responding
to land because the land didn't exist we
had to create the land and then make the
shot within it and that's quite
different you know wasn't like we just
turned up and thought would saw no man
so I thought how we gonna shoot this we
have to make it out of nothing and then
find a way for the camera to Rachel
so sometimes it's the camera dictating
what the set should be and sometimes
it's the other way around but you can't
ever quite put your finger on what came
first and that's why it was such a
unified there's a team effort you know
is a group of us all working at it at
the same time the actors for the whole
of Pratt just rehearsing rehearsing just
walking those roots until we found what
we thought the answer was you co-wrote
the script and I'm curious how did the
script and story change once you started
being in prep and doing all the stuff
with camera moves and
the locations did things change a lot
the story never changed the story
structure was always the same I mean I
always felt very solid about what
happened when and to a certain degree
you can't really change it the trenches
are the trenches no-man's land so where
you know everything had to have a logic
so that didn't change but lots of little
things changed all the time and
particularly because I was watching the
two boys doing it I was able to let them
do it for weeks and just observe them
without directing them particularly hard
and yeah there were lots of little
things that adjustments we made to their
parts but which took it closer to them I
was watching what they were doing
naturally with each other and that way I
was able to make adjustments all the
time the things they probably weren't
even that aware of you know you don't
need to say that line just do that with
a look or you know maybe switch those
lines around and and it just happened
organically so by the time we came to
shoot they were row a rock-solid about
what they were doing what they were
saying how they were moving they've been
wearing their uniforms for six months
they've been handling their weapons
they've been to boot camp have been to
France they've been everywhere and they
were sort of in it and that wasn't
inappropriate because I was encouraging
them to sort of live it as much as to
act it I'm curious which scene which
which one was the toughest one to pick a
take on meaning like did you have a
certain scene that take 10 12 and 14
were all just amazing Oh nearly every
day there was literally you know I was
spoiled for choice and I think when Sam
and I were talking about it we might be
kicking around six brilliant takes you
know and then trying to whittle that
down to the one you know what one gets
to be the one yeah I mean I don't think
there was a day when it was just one
take like that we're always like nobody
talked about the last shot on the movie
because that was a really were very
particular about that though it's the
one that which is the first take that we
use and why oh yes
the one where Blake's brother schoo meet
Blake's brother at the end it's very
it's a highly emotional thing and I
think we had 9 or 12 takes and I
remember and I was watching it the first
take was incredibly emotional like I'm
sitting in Soho not on location looking
at a you know giant screen feeling like
I'm watching a movie and that take
rolled through and I was like choking up
and going oh my god this is amazing like
what a way to end a movie that was take
one and then you know but the other
tapes went through and the acting was
fantastic everything was was incredible
but the camera was getting closer and
closer to Richard Madden blades brother
and it was a tighter and a tighter shot
and then I remember getting to the end
and going wrong you know those last
couple of takes that were amazing but
they still didn't hit me the way the
first take hit me and I went back and
looked at it again and the reason that I
think I really liked it was because the
camera was looser it involved George in
the scene whereas as the camera roll
closer
George kind of lessened in the scene and
I was saying to Sam that it's George's
it's George's film and it needs to be
him and the brother not it's not all
about the brother so we talked about
that and yeah I mean that's a great
example of somebody saying something
that I that I don't think my I certainly
haven't noted on my TV show Roger had
because it was incremental every tape
got a little bit close a little bit
closer and I don't think we noticed it
but the moment Lee said it I thought
he's absolutely right
you know you feel Scofield's presence in
that scene and you and the more we went
on the less and less you felt it now as
it happened on top of I was also very
beautiful performance and Richard and
the Sun came out and all of those other
things but it that's a good example of
why I why Lee was so crucial because
until he said it I absolutely would not
notice that because there's so much
information in the shots you know it's a
long shot the last thing you're looking
at is oh we're about six inches closer
than we were
the first Hey you just don't notice
Roger if I can ask you by the way we did
that deliberately so that any use the
first take I knew it
Roger there are so many amazing shots in
this film I'm curious which one for you
do you I guess is there one that you
felt that was like just really
incredibly difficult to get right or one
you know what I mean if you could just
talk about some of the incredible work
you did well it's difficult for
different reasons I said the hardest
thing it's like I operate or is like you
know walking backwards with two guys in
a trench I mean that was a really hard
but but a lot of it that seems looks you
think was really hard was really hard
but I mean they're going across that
bridging Glasgow we worked it out I mean
we did a mock-up on the back lot in
Shepparton with scaffold towers and the
cranes to this a four-point wire rig and
at one point the cameras taken off the
one then they run with it and go up the
steps to the lock house I mean it looks
an incredibly hard shot and probably if
I watch it again in the year or two I
think my god that's really hard but
because we had so much prep we worked
out the shot Sam said we storyboarded it
a number of times worked out what we
wanted tested it on the back lot we went
to Glasgow and the shot was there the
guys had bricked it
the camera was it's controlled by you
know his computer program so they took
the same program from what we've done in
the back lot and Sheppard and and did it
in Glasgow so when we got there it was
all there I mean we changed the curve
and all that a little bit but it was
basically done so the time we got to
shooting these things on set we'd
rehearse them so many time I mean one of
the hardest shots was the singing
soldier I mean you start coming up the
hill and you don't end until you're
running towards the front line and that
whole choreographed shot of that moving
at sitting
incredibly hard shot for an operator to
do but we spent days and days in a field
with extras rehearsing that shot so by
the time we came to do it for the actors
it was it was pretty well programmed
when you're when you're doing that that
take that scene is there is so beautiful
when it's going on and it's so perfect
how scared are you that one of those
extras is just going to look at the lens
or just you know what I mean yeah it did
happen and you know some but the funny
thing is it's like I was saying earlier
you want to encourage a kind of freedom
as well so you don't want it to be too
sort of a lot you know people terrify
they're gonna [ __ ] up a take you know
and they just that they try too hard
they need to live in the space so you're
trying to actually weirdly encourage not
too much thought I mean a good example
of that is in one of the shots I would
say it's probably one of the most
difficult while certainly on the day was
was but it was exhilarating is that
final run that George takes down that
Scofield takes down the front line as
they're all pouring over the top and and
- you know when he gets knocked off his
feet that was not planned you know that
was extremely adrenaline extra thinking
thing it's what a camera you know and
but you know I'd had said to him
beforehand listen if somebody knocks you
over just keep trying to keep going you
know and he did and and it's in the
movie so that that's what you're looking
for you know and and that happened a few
times even though the camera was pretty
as Roger said we'd roast it so well you
you want life to enter in somehow you
won't mess and and you know there are
animals and babies and the weather
changes and the light changes and
conditions change and you fall in the
mud if you fall in the mud it's your
character falling in the mud get up
again you know and don't let it stop you
and that's obviously something badly
goes wrong you have to stop but most of
the I just encouraged him to get through
to the end and and knowing that knowing
that there was a likelihood I was I
wasn't going to say car and a half the
time if I'd said cut they wouldn't have
heard me anyway because over half a mile
away
the time you know that um but knowing
that gives them a freedom okay they just
gotta go and that also for me comes from
the theater a little bit that thing of
trusting the actor - okay we've
rehearsed a while now it's yours
you take it see what happens and and
trying to find a way of combining that
with everything that we planned on
camera was was part of the challenge
ladies and gentlemen I really want to
say to you guys congratulations on
making one of the best films of this
year it's a stunning cinematic
achievement I'm very much it's just
incredible one more time I want to say a
huge thank you to arc light cinemas a
huge thank you to Universal Pictures a
huge thank you to Roger Deakins Lee
Smith Sam Mendes for doing this QA
thank you and on that note every every
movie needs extra support so if you go
on social please mention if you enjoyed
the movie you know tweet about it
Instagram Facebook whatever you use on
that note thank you for coming out
tonight
thank you
[Applause]